I hear Charlemagne I don't think so
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 298 of the ask gary vee
show and we have a two-time visitor
somebody I admire tremendously somebody
I call friend actually one of my regrets
of this is actually funny I just had
this huge flight to Australia and back
you know you just get fifty hours and in
flight and you get to think and I said
in 2019 as we're starting to get close
to that one of things I'm definitely
gonna do Oh Alex I'm so glad you're in
the room one of the things I have to do
is make a list of 12 15 19 people I just
have to have dinner with them twice a
year oh because I'm just gonna die
regretting that there's these people I
like and normally there are people that
get busy as well and I don't know we
like each other
unless we're showing up on each other's
show it's impossible to like see each
other I know you only had dinner like
once that's right and so like it's just
always gonna be like that and so like I
said wow I'm gonna make a list of just
you know maybe a dirty duck maybe twelve
twelve people and just say yeah you will
talk about it later Alex
then it was popping we ended up with
like Lenny Dykstra some crazy like good
huntin fish club anybody show up at any
time I'm gonna put this I want you guys
to go on I'm live on Instagram as well I
know we weren't on Facebook live I'm
gonna go Instagram live as well because
I want to get questions in and you
didn't do it a little different
I'm gonna I'm gonna shout out right now
I'm gonna wait for Instagram to populate
a little bit I'm gonna let the guests
say hello actually Charla me won't you
say hello to everybody
peace to the planet I go by the name of
Charlemagne to God I am a father a
husband and I guess all the professional
tags that people care about a nationally
syndicated radio personality with The
Breakfast Club podcast host New York
Times bestselling author executive
producer of a couple of TV shows you
know just happy to be here
you've been really really doing it the
last five six feels like the momentum is
substantial over the last
two to three years even yeah but you
know over the last half decade you know
what he is that true and is that a good
observation by me now definitely a great
observation you know everything's been
growing everything's been evolving
that's one of the reasons that things
got very overwhelming you know and I'm
sure you can attest it as Gary when
you're the go-to person for a lot of
people who's like who did the go-to
person go to you know that's what made
me start going it there if you like over
a year ago because after a while
everybody stopped having answers for me
yeah and you know flirtin you know when
I went out what I like to talk to people
who are most successful to me yeah most
people that have way more but you've
done a great job with right I feel like
you've been very one thing I don't do
well is mentor out like I don't I just
flat out really yeah I think what you do
is consider the form of mentorship no no
I like to mentor I [ __ ] love too many
I love it I don't seek out mentorship I
don't learn I don't learn from a dinner
with Jeffrey Katzenberg or Arianna
Huffington I don't I don't know why I
talking in a yeah yes yes but that's
that's the fake answer the reality is I
listen a lot yeah if you watch I cut off
cuz I'm listening it's that I listen to
the mark I don't like synthesized points
of view
I like the market yeah yeah it's what I
want to go to Q&A it's why Instagram by
the way now Instagram is populated
Instagram Facebook if you want to get
your question and you're actually gonna
email something this is different Andy
I've got a new idea I want you to put
your question in the title of the email
and I want you to email where should we
send it should we how fast does it take
us to create an actual email in this
company these days
it better be two point two seconds what
do you got I mean you've got all sorts
of [ __ ] emails we've made up all
right Gary Vee team alright Gary Vee
team at vaynermedia calm put it in the
air if you can you can type it in and
pin it if you want you know how to do
that you're not a pin I'm press write
rag because you say it's Gary Vee team
at vaynermedia calm put your entire
question in the title and he's gonna
start looking at that inbox right now
we're gonna do a bunch of QA action
also actually put it yeah your phone
number you got to be your phone number
in the body question in the title phone
number in the body got it
yeah I don't do a good job with that
sure I mean I'm proud of you for I
actually again you know how well we know
each other but just watching your moves
just sensing even in our interactions of
watching out I think you're very good at
that
yeah and so that makes sense to me cuz I
feel like I don't have a skill set so
it's just like for me I didn't go to
college I don't have any degrees like I
kind of stumbled into the game a radio
so it's just like everything else that's
happening to me I'm not an expert at any
of this stuff so Who am I to give any
advice on anything I just need to shut
up and listen for most of the time most
of the time and you know a lot of people
that I saw who were way more successful
than me they always told me I didn't
went to therapy you know how they talk
to therapists I've been flirting with
the idea for a few years and so I just
decided to start going do you feel like
the stigma of it in the past culture cuz
it's so great one of the most exciting
things in my opinion you go to therapy
I don't okay but one of the most
exciting things for me and I'm not
against it and I let me let me make a
very simple point I'm sure I will
yeah because one of the things is like
you know it's moments in time but like
no question the best thing one of the
best things going on in culture right
now is the stigma is melting very
quickly
yeah huge it feels like the universe is
conspiring for us to just have these
conversations about mental health by the
way when I first started writing this
book I wasn't writing this book from the
perspective of I'm gonna write a book
about my real quick just so I can get it
off my chest
you wrote two [ __ ] books in like
eight seconds 18 months yeah did you
sign a to book deal and you felt
obligated no not at all and the first
one go well and you're like I like that
let me do it again first one did very
well it was a New York Times bestseller
it was on the New York Times's for like
seven weeks great so it did very well
you know how that is all the publishing
start coming to you pressing you hey we
won't do another one of the book I'm
like nope I'll do things for money I
don't care what the check look like yeah
seven figures whatever okay cool so what
hair like if I don't have anything to
write about I don't have anything to
write about and I remember being on
vacation last year with my family
something you don't do often enough get
I do a lot actually like the vacation
look I'm glad
I think seven weeks vacation oh I I
think what I think I've got 2019 needs
to be a year where I clarify a lot of me
I love I love that I'm blessed that I
love what I do so much that I want to do
it a lot but I every weekend off I take
seven weeks vacation I'm just going hard
when I'm on the field and food and I
love my game oh and most of all I don't
want anybody else to do that I want them
to love what they do as much as I do and
if that's working seven hours a day
teaching preschool then you've won I
think like you know I think people
associate listen I talk a lot about work
ethic you know what I am I'm so
passionate against entitlement oh it was
then that I think it clouds a lot of
other things that I talked about were my
truths um I remember you telling me that
I remember you did tell me that you you
you like you do take vacations you do
take that time and I remember you say
that's one of the things you actually
spend money on a hundred percent yeah to
me that's a very great thing to spend on
like like because I'm so like I I so
want that that most importantly I don't
want to focus on anything but sucking
out time with the ones I love yeah so I
don't need any time on logistics like I
don't wanna set up anything or like like
just get me you know overpay for
everything to be frictionlessly so that
exactly and you know what's great about
me perfect is it like if I have shitty
food I'm not the one that's like [ __ ]
that what's perfect to me is I don't
have to do anything other than be like
you know with my brother that's my
sister or my kids you know what I mean
my wife you know so I like what you said
to do cuz I feel that way about success
- success is subjective man like if
you're just happy doing what it is that
you're doing
that's the win like you could be living
in Charlotte North Carolina making
$50,000 a year and your family got a
roof over their head you got a car if
you happy doing what you love doing
you orden to me and by the way I think
that's not far away I feel like I can
see in the same way that if you asked me
six years ago therapy I'd be like you
know I'm starting to see two or three
people talk about it that makes me I
think it's coming yeah I genuinely think
and I'd love to be one of the thousand
faces of happiness needs to be the ROI
now now at the same talk
we can't demonize work ethic because a
lot of people trying to do that too I
love I love it I'm like he loved the
grind we love the hustle but when it's
time to disconnect
I like disconnected fare me too but
people are judging people that are
working a lot and to me it's not about
working a lot it's do you love what you
do yeah like we don't do that to Beyonce
no we don't do that to baseball players
we don't we're doing it to entrepreneurs
but we're not doing it to other people
Elton John's working his face off he's
72 like out there everything like
because they love it some small group of
people love either producing content or
being entrepreneurs the problem is
entrepreneurship got so cool that
everybody wants to be it it's the same
reason that athletes fail so much you
don't think I different no ship is
getting a little bit easier nowadays
though I think there's more opportunity
because the Internet yes but I think
here's the problem everybody thinks
especially young faces that
entrepreneurship means I make a million
a year and to me entrepreneurship and
it's amazing big shout out to Breakfast
Club first of all just cuz it's an
incredible program but that first time I
came through just appreciate your cosign
of like what I spoke about and what I
appreciate and be pushing back because
he didn't know me he's like wait a
minute
like is this this typical you know
motivational [ __ ] white privilege
guys everybody's life is so easy I can
make it and nobody knows my back so I
don't expect anybody put in that work
and he goes give me something tangible
and it led to the flipping [ __ ] yeah I
don't know if you know cuz you're busy
as [ __ ] you shouldn't I see you with
your garage sales it's getting crazy and
show them it where it's really getting
crazy is what I tried to achieve on
Breakfast Club and what I'm trying to
achieve here
fifty seven thousand a year loving the
thrill of the hunt at Goodwill or on
eBay or garage saling versus 71 or 62 or
49 doing something you hate is my dream
of entrepreneurship not uber and
Facebook and Instagram which is what
everybody's looking at know can you make
more selling the dresses you make
handmade then you would working as an ik
can you make by the way let's go big
time can you make 400,000 a year doing a
podcast and selling t-shirts versus
making 380 being a lawyer and she's
living a lifestyle where she needs all
380 to pay for that lifestyle you make a
hundred thousand you make fifty thousand
like to meet us if you're if you build
something from the ground up something
that you created you work for yourself
and you put it out there and you got
people buying your product or buying
into whatever that you whatever it is
you're doing here making 50 got a big
one right now the one that I'm gonna
really zero in on I'm gonna unveil it a
little bit right now if you make eight
to twelve dollars an hour and you have a
car I need to push you to garage saling
it's almost impossible that you can't
make more money flipping than working at
a quick service restaurant or a retailer
mmm and as soon as I get done educating
that anyway nonetheless what's the book
about
it's called shook one anxiety playing
tricks on me and you know I've always
I've done anxiety my whole life you know
I don't have the kind of crippling
anxiety that keeps some people paralyzed
in their house just because sure you
know I just don't I just don't you know
but I've always had what's the worst you
ever had the worst panic attack I ever
had was nine years ago that's when I
first got clinically diagnosed with it I
had just got fired from radio for the
fourth time I had to move from New
Jersey back to South Carolina I was
living with my mom I was like 31 32
years old my daughter was like two you
know my now wife she had to go live back
with her mom and dad in Mouse corner
South Carolina and I remember just
driving down high 26 in South Carolina
and feeling like I was having like a
heart attack like a severe like oh my
god this is it like Fred Sanford this is
the big one honey like right heart
beating crazy fast it was so good
shortness of breath even my arms feel
like they was going down there so
ambitious and talented and you're like
at that point cuz I'm listening to the
data you're like [ __ ] I didn't make it
at the moment I felt like I didn't know
what was next and I remember going to
the hospital and the doctor doing her
EKG on me and he was like yo your heart
is fine he was like yo sound like you
had a panic attack you said do you have
anxiety and I was like no not that I
know of and he was like I use crest out
about anything I'm like [ __ ] you my life
my mind like most hustlers are I'm like
all right so if that's what it is all I
gotta do is get back in position once I
get back in position everything will be
okay but then you know nine years later
and you know you're supposed to be great
in life like you know you're not it
radio show or making all the time
if you're not happy right yeah I mean
I'm I'm happy
is relative you know I mean it's right
yeah but 3% you're really struggling
yeah that's already 3% too much that's
one thing I learn from my therapist
there my therapist always says it's
allow yourself to feel yeah whatever it
is you're going through because you know
we come from at least me I come from the
law of attraction your thoughts become
things which I still wholeheartedly
believe so like those negative thoughts
that delft that my self-doubt that
insecurity you want to push that out of
your brain immediately because you feel
like if you hold on to it too long that
it'll actually come to pass so for me
it's just like you know I try to get
that energy up out of me phone numbers
and ceramic oh I'm sorry
phone number you got an email how do you
know it's coming in good Gary Vee Act
wait team Gary Vee you just made that -
you know we had what oh I'm sorry I
apologize Gary Vee team at vaynermedia
comm put your full question in title and
your phone number in the body and he's
about to call a couple of you let me
just stick on us for one more second
I've been thinking a lot about this
which is why don't I judge myself mmm
mm-hmm
if you ask me why I stay way happier
than I then I think the norm it's
because I think I'm making mistakes all
the time I'm always think I'm losing
even in what appears to be winning
because I am I'm running a big business
I'm doing a lot of things I see it every
day we suck at YouTube nobody you know
like like you know like I I almost like
I do so many things I was gonna buy
unbelievable amounts of Netflix stock
three years ago the phone call hung up
on me on vacation by the way hung up on
me I didn't call him back never did it
you [ __ ] yeah you want to tell some good
[ __ ] man get flipped over like like
going to a business meeting that I have
to go to and my kids have a recital
I can do that easily do you just feel
like it just wasn't meant to be a
hundred thousand percent I know what my
intent is and I know in a net score
loving them and showing them how to be
happy there's because I've met all the
people whose parents went to everything
and they [ __ ] hate their lives yeah
because I'm always like I suck and you I
just think everyone sucks and it makes
it easy here I don't know the guys are
like that's a very pessimistic way of
thinking I just think it's massively
optimistic rule everybody sucks that
means everyone's awesome let's go now I
do feel like my father my father would
always tell me you never as good as they
say you are in this matter they say you
well that's for sure you know so I do
exist in that grade there's another
thing they saying hasn't been able to
penetrate yeah cuz who the [ __ ] is they
I'm just like you can't here's why I
don't take their judgement it's not that
they're wrong and I'm right it's a big
lack context nobody knows what's going
on in my bedroom is out of context yeah
yeah everyone's throwing out judgment
now cuz it's easy yeah cuz the social
media a hundred we always did it now we
just can read it people judge you in the
streets people judge you in the office
rooms people judge you at the cafes you
didn't see it so percent that's the
problem to with the game you know me for
me it's just like you know you get so
much critique from so many different
places I think sometimes subconsciously
if you're not intentionally saying I'm
not listening to none of this [ __ ]
subconsciously it will [ __ ] with you and
it will manipulate you in some ways I
mean most people live their entire lives
dictated by other people's opinions
yeah either your mom or dad which is the
scariest one or the net score of Johnny
pants 47 in your comments yeah I mean
I've gotten caught up in that because
like you know be doing radio for 20
years like especially over the past six
or seven you start reading all of these
magazine articles about you and you see
all these comments about you and they
label you things like hip-hop's Howard
Stern and are a shock jock in this and
that so you start thinking okay if this
is what people like I gotta give them
more of that you become a character
actor yourself and I started and I
always say that's the worst thing you
could be as a character so man I gotta
show you just cuz I need to show you
look how many goosebumps oh I think
about it every day
yeah it's my favorite thing about
actually running a business and not
being garyvee like I it's the reason I'm
garage saling like it's I'm going more
to Who I am
I [ __ ] love garage saling the best
part I think what the most people the
best thing you can learn from this is
being Gavi of being Charlemagne to God
is like you're not being either if
you're not truly being yourself at all
times and being yourself at all times is
acknowledging whatever it is you're
going through in that moment good and
bad acknowledging the thoughts you have
the feelings everything you were more of
a manifested I'm less of a manifested
Amma I just was brought up by a mother
who never put her negativity or issues
on anybody else
and I share her DNA and was conditioned
in it or I just don't share my stress I
take on stress yeah yeah I look that's
just who I am yeah I try to I try to use
that anxiety I turn that fear in the
fuel you know like if I feel anything
negative I try to turn it into a
positive by helping other people that's
what I that's what I realized I feel
like I'm a public servant my favorite
thing is like look let's talk about life
the life is very simple in a lot of ways
people that look like you doing certain
things matter I'm the biggest believer
net okay yeah well so I think when my
grandma used to do something that I
didn't understand when I was a kid we
would watch TV and they would put up
Robert goldstein lawyer for John and
she'd be like eveyday and I didn't even
know what it meant for a long time and
after a while I realized what she was
saying
in Yiddish was jus ooh what I didn't
what and then I didn't like it cuz I was
like she was too like every time a
Jewish person was on TV she
yay and everybody else No and so I saw
that as bad hmm
what I didn't understand until my 30s
was my grandmother lived in suppression
she lived in Soviet Russia where being
Jewish was the worse where her husband
went to jail for being Jewish where that
was the lowest on the totem on a because
of World War two and all that dynamics
you know anti-semitism it's real in
Europe and I was like so what she's all
Monty was happy 100% why she's reppin
our set cuz she never saw it yeah yeah
any other way I feel to say black people
of course you do which is where I'm
going
it makes me so happy that you're going
here because much like there's a lot of
things that Russian Jews and African
Americans and Latinos share and there's
flashy clothes but one thing is like
support like not talking about these
issues yeah it's a story I talk about in
my book I did a study on descendents of
Holocaust survivors and how the
descendants of Holocaust survivors have
so much PTSD and anxiety and trauma and
I'm like y'all didn't do that study or
nobody else in America like you don't
think arrogant Americans go toward I
just think Native Americans don't go
through that so it's just like for me is
just like why not go do the work like we
I work out three four times a week
physically why am I not putting that
same type of assistance in my mind this
is so good man this is so good I'm so
glad this is getting into the water
system yeah it's available for pre-order
right now get in there and it'll be on
October 23rd be up tomorrow let's make
sure we link in a hardener we're live oh
it's tonight tomorrow hey it'll be up
tomorrow we'll make sure you know how
well the last one sold cuz of our show
that's a fact
no you're right I'm we're crossover also
we're calling people yeah we're calling
people no sherry no what's your shot
sherry I don't believe you're really
calling the best part is we leave a
message hello sherry this is Gary
Vaynerchuk
and you're on the askgaryvee show with
Charlemagne the god hey how are you guys
we're doing really well how are you hey
sherry how are you I'm good
I'm good so my question to you guys is
how do you overcome social anxiety like
I'm an entrepreneur I just started my
own web development business I've been
in corporate America for over eleven
years well you know so I have a lot of
experience in that field so far so good
however when I get in some neat things
to like you know close on deals and
contracts you know I get really nervous
I start shaking my lip start shaking my
hands start shaking and you know I don't
want them to just you know just look at
my work and be like okay yeah she does
really good work but at the same time
I'm just so anxious I'm just so nervous
like I want him to take me seriously so
um what do you guys suggest well I
believe in uh two types of anxiety I
believe in irrational anxiety and
irrational anxiety so for you you know
to be about to close big deals and
you're trying to sell something to
somebody you should have a little bit of
anxiousness when it comes today like
it's like me when I approach the radio
every day or I go onstage to present
something like I know I'm doing this to
millions of people so I'm gonna feel
something in my stomach you know but
what you have to do with that fear you
know I got an acronym for fear and it's
face everything and rise or fear
everything and run it sounds like right
now you're being afraid of everything
and running but you just need to rise to
the moment and those in those occasions
because you're supposed to get
goosebumps when you bought the closer
deal are you trying to do you're
supposed to feel like you got to take a
[ __ ]
you know the main hope to feel something
in your stomach so I just think that's
rational anxiety I don't think it's
anything wrong with that you just got to
use that fear as fuel the the other
place that I think is an interesting
place to go is a couple things one you
know this is a self-esteem issue too you
know by you know you're you're making a
very difficult transition for a lot of
people which is the transition of being
an employee in a corporate environment
for over a decade to being an
entrepreneur where it's all on you and
there is often times self-doubt of like
do you think you're worth it like it's
your own self-doubt being imposed on you
something that might not even be coming
out of their eyes does that make sense
yes so like to me let me give you a
really good piece of advice on this
because that's exactly what I thought it
was and this has really worked for a lot
of my team that
wasn't good at selling and now is good
at selling never make a decision for the
other party or and and and value is
subjective do you know that I lose way
more pitches than I win me me Gary right
and here's the funny thing when I lose
them I just blame them like hey like
like like I really I mean that I mean it
like you just have to understand like
there's a million reasons somebody's
gonna say yes or no let's talk about
real life do you know we live in a
society now where some of the
disadvantages are now advantages in in
these in the current climate
some people may give you the business
because they're trying to diversify
their vendors yeah good for you you
deserve it yeah and you know what you're
not gonna apologize for it nope right
some people might have liked one thing
you said somebody might have not liked
something you said I've not given
business to people because I found that
they were Patriot fans that's real I
have not given people business in the
past because even though I thought they
might be the right choice I hate the
Patriots so much petty is [ __ ] the
motivator but it's my one place my
religion somebody suing Gary because of
sports buy you know like literally
literally literally here's what I would
say you have to understand that them
saying no to you isn't because you stink
or because you're not good enough it's
because there's a million variables that
go into somebody saying yes to a vendor
and so when you become numb to it
earlier everybody sucks everyone's good
yeah you're just gonna listen you just
gotta keep pitching and after 200 of
them let's make a judgment you're
definitely worthy of it
you're definitely worthy of it you have
to actually understand you're definitely
worthy of it let me tell you why people
are busy and there's eight billion
options the fact that you got into the
final pitch means you're ready worthy of
it you have to understand that yeah do
you do you see where I'm going yeah
because nightly because you're not
looking at it that way you're looking at
the final call being the worthiness I'm
telling you the fact that you're even at
bat is the worthiness now you have to
karma serendipity and a million
variables that you don't [ __ ] control
take over which lets you let me tell you
what it does back to not being a
caricature of yourself being very full
circle today I'm feeling sharp one of
the reasons I never get too big on
myself is when I win I also know its
variables right yesterday they got
yelled at for not having enough social
media
so today vaynermedia is gonna get the
business not Ogilvy yeah you see where
I'm going just as simple as this person
[ __ ] to my idea this person didn't a
hundred they thought you were funny they
thought you were sweet they thought you
were smartest [ __ ] there's a woman
there's a million variables but the
market decides but it's not a direct
indicator on who you are as a person it
means your business at that moment for
that person the reason I can deal with
negative comments is people haven't
contextualized everything the reason you
can deal with not getting the business
is you don't go home and say I suck I
should go back and get a job I wasn't
good enough you need to realize it was
the serendipity of the moment mm-hmm
yeah you're talking about tonight
darling you're talking about self-esteem
you know that right I get that sometimes
like sometimes I would think that's
probably what it is you know but then
other times I'm like maybe I just need
to get out more maybe I just need to
socialize more maybe I just need to get
in settings where I network Warren
are you saying are you now saying to get
more pitches or to close the actual
pitches just kind of natural pitches
just you know just align myself with
more people in my industry talk about
myself more to do what so that people
just give you the business so you don't
have to pitch or it gives you a better
chance of getting the business when
decision moment comes are just more so
she just work on my own self when it
comes it's not like yeah it's not like
she may be one of these socially awkward
Millennials who was used to talking with
her thumbs so once she gets in front of
people I love you but like I swear my
life I just think that that's a cliche
like ever like that there's they're the
most fifty-three year olds are that way
as well because it because what it all
manifests down to is a level of
confidence yeah like like it's hard to
have it
when you're not in front of your
keyboard yeah but I get it but guess
what I have it on a smartphone I don't
know about that I mean I think a lot of
people get positive reinforcement on the
keyboard they wouldn't get in real life
mmm yes that's what I like you know
because a lot of my feels like I said
what comes from me being behind a
keyboard huh and so on and so forth but
no I've just been getting to a place
where I'm actually like people are
actually saying to me hey come on in so
that we can have a chat with you come in
and show us your work I'm gonna give you
know I'm gonna I'm gonna give you
something so empowering that's gonna put
you in a good mindset mm-hmm just go to
all these pitches the best thing that
can happen to you is going over 800 let
me tell you why I'm a good entrepreneur
because I at six years old rang people's
doorbells and asked them if I could wash
their car that's just facts it's not the
legend of Gary this is like bring out
everybody in Edison New Jersey in 82 83
that's me
can I tell you something about that
ninety-nine out of a hundred homes said
no to me right to my face and I was a
cute six-year-old all you need is one
years baby
all you need is one yes and you're
importantly and more importantly you get
used to no you have to get used to no
it's not what you're wearing it's not
what it's not just not that [ __ ] it's
moments in time and if somebody didn't
want to hire you because of the way you
look or like what you wore I promise you
it saved you time because that's not
gonna be a great client no don't mean
you suck at all no no really I'm not
going to do what you most of the time it
just does it
yeah I'm just keep going let me tell you
something just keep pitching and keep
losing and get used to it
it'll get real good you really start
liking I'm telling you have you sold
anything to a Pichet yes actually just
closed on a really good deal for a
three-year deal with with a company but
you know I'm sorry but what everybody
who's watching right now is like [ __ ]
yeah what's the problem no there is no
problem I just wanted to just know like
we're not going to know or and ask you
are you just lacking a little patience
because you want more oh no that's not
it okay
I was three that was just every day was
different me just asking you know coming
both you guys what are some tips that
you would want you know want to share
with me going forward when it comes to
pitching myself more I think pitching is
the closest thing of sports no different
than going live radio are live on stage
and I genuinely believe a little
competitive anger like [ __ ] everyone is
a good thing I mean it I really do like
it's a sport like you go in there and
really competing with those people even
though you're trying to pitch to them
you know and so I don't know like I
think Charlotte means set it right I
still to this day and I think I'm listen
I think I'm real good at public speaking
I'm doing at the top of the game there's
always still the three to four minutes
before I go on stage where I get into a
weird kind of zone you feel the action
that's a real good point yeah good luck
million TV shows and probably sold four
or five that's all I remember
nobody remembers everybody keep it's
soaked Sports is so good nobody
remembers all of Jordans missed shots
nobody talks about LeBron not breaking
through anymore in fact it's just not
the way you leave your message for eight
zero one nine one keep going you know
what I mean
like it's so like it's just weight is
like that's the problem with social
media to dhoka social medias painting is
unattainable picture of perfection but
here's you see no loo you see no losses
on social media he's trying to put it I
mean I'm like social media is
everybody's highlight reel what but
that's what society's always been that's
what we've always done yeah this is
about actually being raised in an
environment respecting losing that's not
what we do in America no lanza what's up
it's Gary Vee you're on the askgaryvee
show
with Charlotte in the bad what's up Gary
what's up man say hello to Charlemagne
what's up man Lonzo what's happenin
brother stay up stay up you know getting
it like every Monday what's up what's
your question my guy oh man what's the
top things you guys do to keep your
staff or the people around you inspired
it has to happen I couldn't agree more
Charlie the keep what do we do to keep
our staff ins by it yes I think we
people rounded your staff your people
if you give you got the right people
around you and I think the right people
around you will understand that energy
has never lost to describe just merely
transfer from one party to the next so
to keep my people inspired I gotta stay
inspire you know me and my people are a
reflection of me so if my people see me
slacking or my people see me down or my
people see me doubting myself then they
gonna start doubting me and in doubt and
why they work for me you know what I'm
saying so you I think it's a great point
but let me add something else in it's
really fun to have election air in the
room right now it's timing is everything
I do that how long you been on my team
now she's been on my team for a year you
know Maya
I've Tyler and Alex as my admins we're
completely lead by example osmosis
[ __ ] throw in the pool learn how to
swim that's just how we roll you're
about to find out it's just the way we
go however I do think it's super
important when you want to when you feel
it or you feel something I the other day
had to go out to the car it was raining
and I said Alex come take a walk with me
and just checked in just that you know
that that nine-minute walk in the rain
right where I gave her tea umbrella and
just walked like you know I don't want
to speak for her but [ __ ] that [ __ ]
matters it's just good to be heard right
as you know it's good to be heard and
it's dynamics right you know Tyler's the
original admin she comes in she's not
sure like what my interrelationship with
Tyler's were with Andy or with me like
so I'm a big lead by example I'm a big
osmosis I don't like to micromanage but
I'm a big fan of the occasional check-in
create an environment where few people
feel safe I was thrilled with it because
I felt like Alex was telling me the
truth or you know definitely like we did
a lot of good in nine minutes it's just
good to get it out it's also good for
them to see that you're paying attention
to that too otherwise they're just hurt
otherwise they're just collateral for me
it's reverse-engineering them and Alex
may have different ambitions than Andy
and Seth may have different [ __ ] and
Seth may have different ambitions today
than he did when he got on the team a
year and a half two years ago so like
it's just watching them navigate what
are they what are they about what makes
them happy what are they striving for
but look if they're gonna work as close
to me which is unbelievable leverage
yeah I'm gonna be the kind of like we're
gonna have a work ethic that's different
than the rest of Aynor we're gonna have
a longer term view than the rest of
Boehner but the dividends are
extraordinary
I mean nein Trouty idiots I love that
man I love what Gary saying because it's
just like sometimes you want your people
to know that we work with each other
like you don't necessarily work for me
work we work with each other I think I
work for Miami for real for real for
real for real because I'm gonna do mine
you know like like to me like I'm gonna
do mine I'm working I'm a doer like you
know I need help like with things but
like I I think when you really think
you're working for them and you're
checking in and look you know like some
people are good at communicating some
aren't some people complain about
everything
some have pride oh I'm a non complainer
that puts pressure on everybody like if
I've never complained about anything
they're scared to complain about a
16-hour day but they're not me I own the
whole thing they shouldn't have to but
if they want to and they're young enough
and they can do it right now it's gonna
give them so much leverage with me that
that's an interesting bet so I think you
have to you have to decide how much you
care about them for me it's everything
when it all plays out everything's
different timing if you work in
vaynermedia not on Team Gary you can get
quicker results for your hard work with
more short-term upside and less
long-term upside if you work on Team
Gary you get less result I'm talk about
pay and and like downtime like you get
less of that upfront in years 1 & 2 cuz
that's just [ __ ] the way I roll but
you have me for life
after year 3 or 4 I'll [ __ ] I'll do
everything for Andy for the rest of my
life
the only vulnerability of that bet is if
I die I'm not kidding so if he's in the
will not yet but like but honestly like
and for me the will is a funny thing
altogether too for me it's more about
putting the you know who's Andy of 52
what's he gonna care about like you know
like at you know if it plays out the
right way the way I wanted to it's never
about the will it's about putting people
in a position of doing back to happiness
over money I was in ROI you know like I
don't know who here wants to be a Dean
of a school let me tell you something
right now every Dean of every College in
37 to 42 years I can place because the
whole game is gonna be reread maybe they
want to be
percent you know that you guys say stay
inspired stay inspiring guys
Gary turn my world around eight years
ago brother and why I love you why man I
just I just I just started listening and
then I started doing and then it turns
off for like six months and then I
turned you back on every once in a while
but I've been able to follow those steps
and and and learn from my team and
people and building it what's what's the
biggest thing that what's the biggest
thing that like you completely were like
oh [ __ ] I'm 8 years ago what was the
biggest thing that I eliminated from you
through the content man
self-pity doing like you know blaming
others I just switched it and I'm like
you know what if I'm gonna succeed or
fail it's on me
100% that's it take responsibility and
you know take credit and responsibility
and give love to the people around you
that are there from you from day one and
it just keep going no excuses no and you
know I appreciate brother I appreciate
thank you so much and you know what you
know even here's the best part it
doesn't mean that everything like when I
say everything's my fault it doesn't
mean that that's true it means that it's
just a happy place to think about it
feels empowering you know like people
get mad at me they're like Gary what
about what about like you're right you
know any of those things happen to me
there's a million outside forces but
like you know it's really exciting to be
able to think about like I could
possibly do something about this while
to your point earlier still recognizing
like whether it's grieving or being
disappointed about it you have to be
able to do that but it's just you know
to me it's like what's the alternative
I think accountability is very important
you know even even if it's even if it
may be outside sources that are
manipulating the situation or against
you in a situation I still gotta realize
like what I do in this
poby obey po'pay it's Gary Vaynerchuk
turn on the askgaryvee show with
Charlemagne the guide how are you what's
up okay
oh my gosh excited what's your question
oh if you're stuck in a marital position
and there's issues were
two people are on different
entrepreneurship lifestyle one only
believes of Mayors and not helping their
self do you just say [ __ ] it let's get a
divorce Laurel in several ways or you
continue and do your own thing and it's
be married I don't know you give
relationship advice to yeah it's it's
just very real life it by the way I
don't think most people can be
successful entrepreneurs if they don't
have healthy relationships because the
support system for somebody that's
trying to make it happen is very real
mmm-hmm look I mean look look it's never
fun to sit around and and not know any
context and be like you should get a
divorce yeah like that might make good
content but that's scary right here's
what I will say I think if you dig a
level deeper that's where you start
getting into the interesting stuff right
I get a lot of men and women who hit me
up and they're like man my partner is
just like not about it and not
supporting me in any shape or form and
doing this than the other thing and the
question is is that an insecurity or a
shortcoming of the partner that it's a
subconscious misery loves company thing
that's just very real in society and
also are you blaming are you blaming
other emotions on the business is he a
good husband outside of y'all not being
on the same page entrepreneur wife no I
don't wanna yeah I get it I get it was
symbolic you don't have to the AHS
enough yeah III let you do what you do
you do everything I support you to 100%
like I can't I get that same support
exactly I believe in I show you if you
see if you see my vision and you think
there's success in it then then why are
you not helping me why are you not
supporting me so real quick real quick
helping and supporting are two different
what the way most people use the words
helping I'm okay with like like if my
spouse was like I don't believe in that
at all like I don't want to do the work
like I don't want to give you money I
don't want to pack your packages at
night I'm amazingly cool with that I'm
amazingly cool with that
but not supporting emotionally not being
a cheerleader or a
well I call it cheerleaders and
fullbacks either you're gonna help me
clear the lane so I can run that's
packing the packages things of that or
you're gonna be a cheerleader which is
like blindly like you could [ __ ] do
it
if you're not willing to do one of those
two things you can't be the most
important person in my life yeah yeah
that's what I was afraid of I just want
to make sure that you like sometimes
spouse is like yo my [ __ ] visions on
point you pack my like the eBay thing is
actually coming up a bunch they're like
yo I'm doing it I'm finding [ __ ] at
garage sales and thrift stores I want my
husband or I want my wife to pack the
[ __ ] and ship I'm like hmm you want them
to do the shitty thing you know you know
like and if they don't believe in it cuz
you shouldn't believe in it it's weird
you just told your spouse instead of
making 78k year being this executive
Gary Vee [ __ ] told you that you can
garage sale and make a hundo like
they're scared rightfully so because
it's hard to get 278 K and garage sale
and Amazon you gotta get good but but
one or the two if he if if he and this
is now macro if he or she is not willing
to be a fullback get in the trenches
with you or a cheerleader they're not in
the trenches they're on their own [ __ ]
even if they're lazy let alone doing
something on their own they better be
saying I hope you're crushing it you're
the best
you can do it if they're not doing
either one of those things then what are
they doing that grounds for divorce
divorce I think you got other issues no
no it's mostly the support issue it's
just like when you're when you're
they're doing everything for the other
person the other person just like
totally ignores you as a person it's
more than just because the business side
is just like he's a straight
entrepreneurship or entrepreneur but
it's just like okay so if you're afraid
that I'm gonna be more successful than
you and I don't really want to I don't
think yeah I think I think that that
correlation isn't true like I've seen it
too much I've been in a gym enough with
people that I think are emotionally
stable like I don't think that
correlation is as true as people think I
think that what's happening is the fact
that matter is if you don't feel here's
what I would say is
grounds for divorce maybe but what you
have to have is a real conversation of
like yo [ __ ] you you don't support me
emotionally for [ __ ] and we're humans
out here and unless you're willing to
give that and if this is either out of
insecurities that I might pop and be
bigger than you or you just don't even
give a [ __ ] cuz you're all about you
that needs to be a conversation
what you said is key just now emotional
support it sounds like there's a lack of
emotional support that has nothing to do
with entrepreneurship you just want
somebody wanting is manifesting in the
entrepreneurial game go ahead a lot
because the thing is I'm a stay-at-home
mother but yet I still grind like I do
like not like totally garage sale but
I'm still working on the folder
ourselves but I did doing like a lot
where I slept like a thousand dollars
with a baby club kids like it's easy you
know say that one more time what the
easy part yeah flip the baby clothes for
like a thousand is like a few months not
even six months and like got a thousand
dollars Wow you got like I I get made
fun of because I'm like oh look I can
flip back somebody send them I listen do
me a favor put them on everybody who
makes fun of you for flipping for now on
in the history of your life send a DM on
Instagram to me and that person and be
like yo my friend Gary Vee wanted you to
make fun of us in this DM go put your
[ __ ] parents on there first
parents are the biggest [ __ ] problem
parents are [ __ ] the biggest problem
in society because parents use children
as collateral for their own self esteem
and it needs to [ __ ] stop yeah most
definitely because her my said I am my
son I know he's not really technically
full college smart but we're working on
us you know who wasn't full college
smart me and Charlemagne never went to
college I went to Maui to college I
played Madden all day that's what I
majored in Madden Selo
spades hearts flip and [ __ ] I was doing
it then that's what I majored in I did
when I wasn't college ready I did one
week of trident Technical College in
Charleston South Carolina and looked
around the room and said why am i here I
need to be at the radio station why am I
here and I looked around in the first
week and said this for years
Haitians gonna be the greatest [ __ ] of
my life can't wait because I'm gonna
work my [ __ ] face off for the rest of
my life yeah a lot of parents don't want
their kids parents are insecure and care
about other people's other parents
judgment on their kid and they don't
understand not and they don't understand
non-traditional hustles you know I'm
saying if your fifth my mom's a school
teacher my father did construction I
tell them I want to do radio you like
radio hell is that yeah I'm an immigrant
my kids are first first-generation kids
no therefore the way that I grew up is
definitely different a way that we doing
I'm parenting is definitely different
for my parents and the thing is like
look there's opportunities out there and
this is like the age of technology like
you got it there's a lot of year old
babies they're out there get let me let
me let me let me give you two cents do
it what you want you I like everything
I'm hearing for real I mean this just
over I can hear you listen I can hear
you mean genuine is [ __ ] with us
ready one thing one thing massively over
communicate with your parents and your
husband and everybody else to put it on
wax put it on the record because a lot
of people just make these decisions I'm
one of them all in their own head and
then they move and they expect everybody
that did something wrong to just deal
with the collateral damage which is in
my opinion fair what's even better so
that you have no regret when you die I
want you to highly consider being as
authentic because you're keeping [ __ ] in
being as authentic as humanly possible
to all three of them over authentic for
the record the [ __ ] you I love you how
can we do this if we can't cool [ __ ] you
that talk and then you can really move
because you're giving them the
opportunity to adjust cuz they can't
read your dome either yeah do you
understand yeah and people like you and
I because I can feel it already
we're not as good at that do you
understand yeah so so you live with no
regret one last at-bat to over
communication for the record giving them
a month
or to navigate that new data then make a
decision and she may need a mediator you
might want to try a couples therapy
couples therapy trust me I've been there
done that I've exhausted every option
couples therapy already I'll just I'll
just say the only thing that he accepted
was therapy with his married a couple
friend and that bet listen one this is
super simple
leave one manifesto on the table for
perpetuity between you and him and you
and your folks so that nobody's confused
what's in your head nobody full 100%
truth then you can navigate lightly as a
feather
to happiness for yourself and your kids
forever thank you and I'm pretty sure
some that people are gonna figure out
who this is not sure
ready on the shore and people watching
this show so you know listen I wish I
wish you nothing but the best thank you
that was real that was very honest it's
really about that is what's real about
this which is real conversation which is
very simply the Internet is gonna expose
everything anyway yes there's no hiding
so be transparent so move into it we
live in the age of transparency it's
easier to wake up every day and just be
yourself like I'm coming we're gonna
link this who should get this book in
your opinion who's watching or listening
on the podcast right now because when
air this in different times a clip from
these things who should pick up this
book and a team let's make sure we link
all about anybody who suffers from
anxiety anybody who suffers from PTSD
trauma anybody who feels like they're to
go to a guy and go to a girl and they
don't have a go-to person to go to
themself you know cuz I'm talking about
a lot of the therapy that I've been
doing over the past year in this book as
well so I just think it's for anybody
who's got any of these so-called mental
health issues that they haven't chosen
to deal with I chose to deal with my
question day that was just enough you
keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]